تتحدث الآن أم لخمسة أطفال نجت من كوفيد
وأمضت شهرين في غيبوبة
عن صراعها القريب مع
الموت ،
يجب أن أقول إن أندريا أرياغا
بورجز كانت غير محصنة عندما أصيبت
بالفيروس وهي معنا الآن ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لكونك  معنا إنه لأمر
رائع أن أراك ، أنا سعيد جدًا
لأنك كنت هنا معنا وأنا أتساءل فقط
إذا كان بإمكانك أن تبدأ بإخبار
مشاهدينا
بما مررت به كنت في غيبوبة
لمدة شهرين وأيضًا عنك
الشفاء ، لقد
أثبتت الاختبارات الإيجابية
في التاسع عشر من مايو
، وفي غضون خمسة أيام
كنت في فترة
ما من هناك ، كنت في غيبوبة
لمدة 65 يومًا
، وهنا لا أستطيع أن أصدق ذلك ، لقد
قضيت ما مجموعه
أربعة أشهر ونصف  في المستشفى ،
ما زلت أحصل على
صوت خشن قليلاً من
أنني أعاني من شق القصبة الهوائية ،
ولم أستطع المشي ،
فقد فقدت مهاراتي الحركية ، وفقدت كل
عضلاتي ،
وانخفضت حوالي 35 رطلاً
وعادت إلى المنزل على كرسي متحرك ، تعلمنا كيفية
القيام بذلك  المشي مرة أخرى
وبشكل
أساسي لم يكن لديك ماء
أو طعام
ج  لن أتحدث
لمدة أربعة أشهر
وسنوات ،
إنه أمر رائع ، وظنت أندريا عائلتك
أنهم سيخسرونك ،
نعم ، أخبر الأطباء أطفالي
أختي زوجي
أن لدي فرصة بنسبة 5 في المائة للبقاء على
قيد الحياة
وحتى لو فعلت ذلك.  أكون في المستشفى
حتى يناير على الأقل
وعدت إلى المنزل
29 أغسطس ،
لذا أتساءل الآن ما هي رسالتك
عن اللقاحات كشخص
يعرف هذا القرار بالبقاء
غير محصن ،
كنت ضده
ولا أريد أي شخص  لتصفح ما مررت
به والشيء الوحيد الذي يمكنني قوله هو
مجرد إضافة تلك الطبقة الإضافية من الحماية
والحصول على التطعيم ، احصل على المعزز ،
أشعر أنه يجب أن يكون لدى الجميع
خيار
ولكن في نفس الوقت
يتعلق الأمر بحماية نفسك والآخرين ،
هل يمكنك ذلك  هل يمكنك أن تأخذنا إلى
تفكيرك كما تعلم قبل أن تكون مريضًا ،
لماذا
لأنني أعتقد أن الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يشاهدون
هذا سيتساءل لماذا استغرق الأمر
ما يقرب من الموت لتغيير رأيك بشأن اللقاحات
كنت بصحة جيدة لم يكن لدي  المشاكل الصحية الأساسية
ليس مدخنا لا يعاني من
الربو
لم يكن يعاني من أي مشاكل في القلب
ولا مشاكل في الرئة
ولم أكن أعلم
أنه سيؤثر علي بالطريقة التي
اعتقدت أنني سأمرض بها لمدة أربعة
أو خمسة أيام
و  ثم
كن على ما يرام
وهذا ليس كيف سارت الأمور على ما
يرام أندريا ii أشكرك كثيرًا
على وجودك معنا لمشاركة قصتك ، أنا ممتن
جدًا لك ولعائلتك
وأطفالك الخمسة الذين كنت هنا لمشاركة هذا
معنا